[Music]
Seana is in tampa florida hi Shawna
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so my question is I am
due to have a baby in a couple weeks
congratulation my thank you My partner
and I have not gotten married yet he
wants to get married
I've been resistant because I have a
Native American subsidy through a health
place marketplace which I'll lose once
we get married so I've been kind of
postponing that but my question is I
sold a house in Colorado so I have a big
chunk of money just sitting in my
savings account about $100,000 and I'm
wondering what what should I do with
that I was going to help pay some money
down on I guess it's his house because
we're not married yet but try to get
that down and then our plan was to
refinance next year after we get married
would you say fifty thousand on that
money no I'm not married to you and
you're giving money wait a minute you're
not married to well it's I mean we see
that you're sweet me some money and he
actually we both owned houses in
Colorado which we both sold it is to pay
down somebody else's house well it's out
so don't do that till it's our house
right you're saying yeah you have no
ownership position you might as well go
knock on the next-door neighbor's door
and give them 50 grand it's the same
thing from a legal position you
understand okay yeah it's like like
you're you know your friend lets you
spend the night in their bed in their
spare bedroom one night so you put 50
grand down on their mortgage it's kind
of the same thing he put me on the deed
yeah I could but now you got a general
partnership which is dangerous as crud
there's no way to undo this mess listen
you need to decide you need to paint or
get off the ladder
okay are we gonna be married or are we
gonna just walk around acting like
were married if you're gonna walk around
acting like you're married keep your
stuff completely separate because then
you just have a roommate if you're gonna
be married then combine everything but
don't combine stuff when you're not
married it leaves you so vulnerable and
it really is gonna leave you looking
foolish if this thing unravels on you so
yeah I'm you know I'm an old-fashioned
guy I'd say get married and there's all
kinds of data by the way aside from my
Christian faith but there's all kinds of
socio-economic data that says that
people who are married succeed much more
than those are shacking up they live
longer they prosper more they have
higher incomes they're healthier
I mean it's bizarre what the what the
actual data points come out to be and
it's kind of lost on this you know some
some folks who think they've got you
know got this all figured out but turns
out God had a real plan and he cares
about you and it involves marriage so
you do what you want to do honey I mean
if you were my daughter that's exactly
what I would tell you though and I'm
always going to tell you the truth not
cuz I'm trying to get entertainment
value out of you because I care about
you I want you to win this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]